[Música]
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres alertó del impacto que puede
tener en materia del clima la carrera
que muchos países están emprendiendo
para reemplazar cuanto antes las
importaciones de gas y petróleo ruso
según él los líderes se ven tan
obsesionados por la carencia inmediata
de suministro de combustibles fósiles
que descuidan o dejan a un lado las
políticas para reducir el uso de
combustibles fósiles además aseguró que
las medidas a corto plazo para sustituir
el petróleo del gas ruso pueden crear a
largo plazo la dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles y hacer
definitivamente imposible el
cumplimiento de las metas fijadas en el
acuerdo de país de parís para así
combatir el cambio climático que busca
entre otras cosas limitar a 1.5 grados
la subida de las temperaturas con
respecto a la media de la era
preindustrial para eso entonces quiero
saludar en este momento ha gustado un
amanecer es coordinador de cambio
climático para américa latina y el
caribe el programa de la onu para el
medio ambiente gracias gustado por estar
con nosotros en directo
france24 se olvidaron de la crisis
climática los líderes mundiales tras
esta guerra
hola buenos días un gusto estar contigo
pareciese que si pareciese que la
respuesta a esta urgencia de la invasión
rusa de ucrania pues ha hecho olvidar
pues lo que dice el secretario general
no nuestra adicción a los combustibles
fósiles que es una fuente de asegurada
de destrucción mutua en este último año
hemos tenido un 6 por ciento de
incremento en las emisiones prevemos que
estemos antes del año 2030 en un aumento
del 14 por ciento si seguimos una
trayectoria como la que estamos llevando
ahora mismo por lo tanto el cambio
climático
aumentaría sus impactos si ya tenemos
una crisis energética
profunda como estamos viendo por esta
invasión
y puede que haya una crisis de seguridad
alimentaria por todos los descalabros en
la producción agrícola que pueden
suceder y a eso le añadimos una crisis
climática la perspectiva no es positiva
gustado porque no aprovechar todo este
contexto de la guerra este contexto de
la crisis de energía para así acelerar
la transición a la energía limpia que
realmente pues es lo que todos queremos
es el objetivo que está totalmente
empañado
efectivamente si aceleramos la
transición a las energías renovables a
la movilidad eléctrica cortaremos
nuestra dependencia de los combustibles
fósiles nos haríamos menos dependientes
también de esa volatilidad que causa
consumir el gas uso para los países
europeos
seríamos digamos soberanos
energéticamente y tendríamos una
economía mucho más fuerte no porque no
tendríamos esos costos tan altos
producir electricidad con el sol sabemos
que durante 30 a 40 años va a tener el
mismo costo eso a nivel de las empresas
les da muchísima seguridad no entonces
no lo estamos haciendo por por esa
adicción que tenemos por esa
respuesta inmediata que le están dando
muchos tomadores de decisión
a los combustibles fósiles porque creen
que esa es la solución hay muchos
intereses creados hay un vínculo muy
estrecho entre ciertos gobiernos y
ciertos lobbies o ciertas empresas
fósiles
cortar esta elección qué tan difícil es
hacer esa transición de energía además
por lo que usted dice no es nada
alentador realmente si vamos a cumplir
los compromisos porque finalmente todo
lamentablemente se queda en el papel y
además luego de la 26 que fueron
bastante ambiciosos líderes mundiales
pero cuando vamos a la práctica es
totalmente lo contrario como si nada
hubiera pasado como si nos hubieran
reunido y no hubieran hablado y no
estuvieran pues viendo lo que está
ocurriendo con nuestro planeta con toda
la crisis climática
definitivamente parece a veces que el
discurso la palabra vaya por un lado y
la acción vaya por otro y ahí hay una
incoherencia política tremenda y esa
falta de alineamiento es la que nos
mantiene
amarrados a este gran problema sin
embargo las soluciones son sencillas son
técnicamente probadas y los buenos que
son más barato hasta que la dependencia
de los fósiles como estamos viendo ahora
mismo con los precios de la energía
alrededor del mundo no solamente en
europa
por ejemplo producir electricidad a
través del viento oa través del sol es
mucho más rápido instalar un campo a
gran escala a través de energía solar
que crear una planta regasificadora en
exploración de petróleo es mucho más
rápido y es mucho más barato entonces si
eso pasa y sabemos que es así el
problema no es técnico el problema ni
siquiera es financiero el problema es
político no hay voluntad de hacerlo